democratic presidential candidate joe
biden says voters should have a say in
who replaces ginsburg
if donald trump wins the election then
the senate should move on his selection
and weigh the nominee he chooses fairly
but if i win this election president
trump's nominee should be withdrawn
cbs news has confirmed the president's
top candidates include
two federal appeals court judges amy
coney barrett and barbara lagoa
barrett was also on his list of
candidates in 2018 before he ultimately
picked justice brett kavanaugh
democratic senator amy klobuchar is a
member of the senate judiciary committee
so she'll be directly involved
in the confirmation of the next supreme
court justice she joins us now senator
good morning
thank you so much it's great to be on
senators
senator schumer said over the weekend
that nothing is off the
table if republicans moved to fill
justice ginsburg's seat kaylee mcininney
told us this morning there will be a
nomination
this week what are democrats prepared to
do
to fight back i think the first question
to ask is actually what are the
republicans going to do
given that they set their own precedent
just four years ago when they made it
very clear that if this happens in an
election year
that whoever wins the election should be
able to decide
who the supreme court justice is if
people choose the president
the president chooses the nominee then
you have
the actual wishes of ruth bader ginsburg
her last words my most fervent wish
is that i will not be replaced until a
new president
is installed but senator that's clearly
that's clearly not happening the
president says he's going to put out a
nomination this week
sure what are you going to do
again we already have two republican
senators
that disagree with this and there could
be others
so i'm not going to concede that we have
to look at what our strategies are
until we know that they are all going to
basically sell out to mitch mcconnell
they are independently elected but in
their states
they made a pledge basically last time
many of them said this should be regard
to the election and who picks
and let me add one more thing if you
look at history the only time that
someone has died of justice this close
to the election
you have to go back to abraham lincoln
and that wise leader what did he do
he said i'm going to wait till after the
election
to nominate someone and we will then
have a vote after the
election that's history and that's a
wise leader
and so regardless of what donald trump
is going to do this week
my colleagues don't have to go lockstep
with him they
can look in their own souls and their
integrity and make a decision
so i'm not going to concede whatever
strategies we have to
deploy before we see what they do
as you said senator susan collins and
lisa murkowski republicans
are both opposed to filling the seat uh
this close to the election
do you think there will be other
republican votes
i hope so i mean a reuters poll just
came out yesterday
that showed that 62 percent of americans
believe that
whoever wins the election should pick
this justice
five out of ten republicans in that poll
said the same thing
uh so they're going to have to listen to
their own constituents and there
are a number of them that have not yet
said where they are
on this and so uh that is that's my
focus right now
really appealing to their sense of
democracy uh the sense of justice
and we will go from there because ruth
bader ginsburg a hero an icon a woman
ahead of her time and i'm just not going
to give up because she
never gave up i mean they told her she
couldn't go to
law school and she graduated first in
her class they told her that men should
argue the cases on equal protection
she said no i'll do it and she won she
got on the supreme court as only the
second woman appointed after sandra day
o'connor
to the nation's highest court and she
became a cultural icon
in her eighties i know senator was
possible
you're right about that we could say
that she certainly persisted and she was
certainly beloved
it seems on both sides of the the aisle
but the truth of the matter is to get
back to anthony's point for just a
second the numbers are against you so
are democrats putting pressure
on republicans to look in their soul as
you say to do in your opinion the right
thing
are you pressuring people you and your
your colleagues behind the scenes and if
so
we are talking to people and reaching
out to them
but i also believe the voters are going
to do that that's why i just mentioned
where the numbers are
in the country they're voting right now
gail
25 states have already started voting
and
the rest will soon follow early voting
in my state they're actually going to
in-person poll voting and so that's
happening right now
who do you think has more sense think of
what's on the line health care's on the
line
voting rights is on the line
environmental rules while people are
choking on smoke out in the west coast
on the line november 10th is the
affordable care act case people
literally could be kicked off their
insurance for pre-existing conditions
but senator there's a boat
there's a lot on the line for both sides
both sides will tell you there's a lot
on the line so
who do you think has more incentive to
go to the polls
because of this latest turn of events
and this isn't even the october surprise
who do you think has more incentive the
democrats or the republican voters
first of all uh joe biden has a bunch of
moderate republicans and independents
supporting him so let's remember
a former uh governor kasich of ohio
actually spoke at the convention
joe biden is leading in states no one
ever thought he could lead in
because of the fact that democrats are
going to turn out in droves but
independents and moderate republicans
so many of them are supporting him
because they've had it with this divide
they've had it with a president who
literally is trying to get rid of the
affordable care act
in the middle of a pandemic who cannot
manage this
just this weekend 200 000 people we got
to that number
have died i had to go visit my dad
through a glass door
when he had covered not knowing if it's
the last time i'm going to see him at
age 92.
that's happening to so many americans
and they have had it
senator klobuchar thank you so much for
being with us this morning well thank
you it was great to be